your next role I'm told is quite
interesting well it's part of my
philosophy of finding diversity and the
work that I do yeah it's a movie that
thirty years ago I probably wouldn't
have accepted this role but I am now
honored and delighted to be playing the
role of the emoji poop this is it's it's
the emoji movie it's the emotionally
emoji movie it's animated of course yes
yeah I'm poop
the more times I can get you in this
interview to say Sir Patrick Stewart I'm
poop the more delighted I will be a lot
of people have said for years Patrick
Stewart's acting is and well now I'm
going to prove to them it's true so I'm
just curious so there are many emojis
many emojis to play and you are playing
the the poop emoji mm-hmm what was that
conversation like when you get the call
and it's your agent and he says sir
Patrick I have some news for you how's
this go you've had an offer it's an
animated movie so it's going to be a
voiceover and it's gonna be about emojis
which I use and very familiar with them
and then he said I don't know how you're
going to feel about this but the role
they've offered you is and it flashed
into my head before he said it but I
listened to him say who it was not far
and I said yes
[Applause]
how diverse couldn't emoji roll guess
yes I mean poop is it yes the one so I'm
not curious
so I'm guessing I'm imagining you you
won't know how I prepared that roll yes
wow that's a man I don't know if I want
to go there oh well what's your okay
research yeah how are you how are you
buddy yeah how are you going to approach
the character without giving too much
away do you think with nose plugs on no
we're already halfway through I've
recorded the role once already in Rio
with animated movies you go back so I'm
waiting to hear further from the
production company but he is a very
upright very proper rather cultivated
sounding Englishman which you would
expect yeah I love that you went yes
exactly it's not exactly what you would
think right away but I love that you're
taking poop in that direction well not
me but I'm sorry would you say that line
again no no I'm not gonna say that again
I just wanted you to talk about this you
have and I'm delighted I'm moving on
you